we know zombies are all about chowing
down on brains but in plants vs. zombies
garden warfare if you aren't using your
own brain a little bit you're gonna be
pushing up sunflowers while they stare
down smiling at your fetid decaying
corpse so here are some tips to help you
overcome those smug son loving
so-and-so's the zombies generally work
well as a group given that garden
warfare isn't a very low wolf friendly
game you'll be at your deliquescent best
when you and your teammates are using
your abilities to help each other out
when you run into a group of plants the
first one in should be the all-star not
because he's particularly powerful mind
you in fact he's liable to lose a
one-on-one gunfight but his abilities
are disruptive and can change the
landscape of battle to your advantage if
properly timed start out with a sprint
tackle to ko or knock back any greenies
that get in your way
once your charge ends punt an imp
towards the nearest cluster of foes and
throw up tackling dummies immediately
afterwards your explosive minion will
hopefully damage or scatter your enemies
and your dummies will provide vital
cover for your allies to advance stay
behind the dummies lay down lateral
covering fire until your sprint tackle
recharges and pray to zombie vince
lombardi that a chopper doesn't come
after you
the workhorse of the zombie army is the
foot soldier is z1 assault blaster can
do decent damage at most ranges and it's
the best zombie weapon for taking down
those nightmarish cyclopean garlic
drones so always keep an eye on the sky
the zpg rocket takes a second to unleash
but the high Splash Damage can devastate
groups of weedy bad guys detonate
minefields and knock down nut walls like
every projectile or deployable ability
you should remember to use the cpg at
least once per life saving it for the
right time can help turn the tides but
dying without using it just makes you
even more of a festering flesh pile than
you already are
the foot soldier can also uncork a
zombie stink cloud which is very helpful
in the gardens in graveyards mode the
purple smoke acts as a screen to obscure
your shambling advances and could cause
chaos on a capture point and when the
going gets tough the tough do the squid
jump pop smoke trigger the rocket jump
and yell squid man away into the Kinect
voice chat and hopefully don't have any
Skype contacts called squid men
[Music]
speaking of gardens and graveyards in
this mode the engineer zombie has an
absolutely crucial role to play as soon
as the match begins or as soon as you
capture a garden hop on that jackhammer
jiggle your decaying butt crack straight
to the purple wrench icon on the map and
build that teleporter build it so hard
and remember you can still shoot while
building so if some speedy pea shooters
get up in your face either blast them
with your gun or stop building and stun
them with your megaphone grenade then
set yourself up some friendly little
turrets upgrade them to mark two and
take a breather because zombies are
notoriously averse to cardio once the
coast is clear send your drone up to be
a total pain in the stamen despite
having a helmet the drone is really weak
and is best used to needle foes that are
already fighting your allies and if you
wait a few seconds before you expose
yourself to enemy fire you'll be very
close to unleashing the airstrike
ability that packs a decent wall up and
can clear out a minefield in no time
finally we've got the scientists a weird
googly eyed dude who plays an important
support role what with the purple
healing hydrant and the speedy revival
times in team vanquish every zombie you
revive is a point you denied to the
plants so revives are super important
those chubby golden crosses are your key
to victories so go get scientific on
them or whatever you do this class can
also do some decent flanking maneuvers
thanks to the scientists warp ability
being able to close distance on plants
is crucial for any zombie as plants
generally have the advantage at long
distance a quick warp can put that pesky
cactus on the business end of your goo
blaster so good oh and mines don't
forget to throw mines mine the main
lanes and mine the side alleys mind the
garden and just mind the everything's
spend the mines the time it takes for
your abilities to recharge does span
across lives so there is some strategic
value in saving stuff for the perfect
moment but you'll never know what the
perfect moment is until you use that
stuff a lot
so seriously use your abilities revive
your allies shamble together and tear
those organic offenders leaf from limb
zombies
[Applause]
[Music]
you